U
THAT MAKE THE SHOW POSSIBLE.
BUT OUR WORK IS FAR FROM OVER.
TONIGHT, MY HEART'S QUITE
TROUBLED.
MITCH McCONNELL, WHERE IS YOUR
BACKBONE?
WHERE ARE YOUR PRINCIPLES?
MOMENTS AGO, MITCH McCONNELL
AND TEN OTHER WEAK REPUBLICAN
SENATORS, GAVE THEIR DEMOCRATIC
COLLEAGUES ARE VERY GENEROUS
GIFT.
WHEN THEY'VE BEEN TELLING US FOR
TWO MONTHS THEY WOULD NOT GIVE
THEM.
THAT'S A BIG NEW EXTENSION.
EVERYBODY IN THIS COUNTRY IS
GOING TO PAY THE PRICE.
UNTIL YESTERDAY, REPUBLICANS
HAVE BEEN COMPLETELY READY DON'T
LIKE UNITED.
THEY WERE COMPLETELY
IGNORED AND SHUT OUT BY
DEMOCRATS.
ON THE BUDGET, THE PROCESS, AND
THEY PROMISED US, YOU, WE, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, THAT THEY WOULD
NOT ASSIST DEMOCRATS IN RAISING
THE DEBT CEILING.
DEMOCRATS CAN DO AND ALL ON
THEIR OWN.
DEMOCRATS WERE PANICKING ON
CAPITOL HILL.
THEY HAD ENOUGH VOTES, THEY
COULD HAVE RAISED THE DEBT
CEILING ALL SUMMER LONG AND
RAMMED IT THROUGH THEIR OWN
RECONCILIATION.
THEY DID NOT NEED THE HELP OF
MITCH McCONNELL AND TEN OTHER
WEAK REPUBLICANS.
BUT THEY CANNOT GET IT DONE.
WHY?
THE RADICAL SOCIALIST DEMOCRATS
AND THEIR SLIGHTLY LESS RADICAL
SOCIALIST COLLEAGUES, THEY
COULDN'T COME TO TERMS.
TRILLIONS AND TRILLIONS OF
DOLLARS, GREEN NEW DEAL
SOCIALIST SPENDING, AND MASSIVE
NEW TAX HIKES, RECORD TAX HIKES,
RECORD SPENDING, RECORD
REGULATION, AND ALL THEY ARE
TRYING TO DO NOW IS RAM THIS
THROUGH IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT.
ALONG WITH A DEBT CEILING.
DEMOCRATS COULDN'T COME TO
TERMS, THEY WERE THREATENING TO
BLOW UP THE LEGISLATIVE
FILIBUSTER.
THAT'S RIGHT, WE WILL GO TO THE
NUCLEAR OPTION.
INSTEAD OF FORCING THE DEMOCRATS
HAND AS THEY SAID THEY WOULD,
INSTEAD OF CALLING THEIR BLOOD
FENCE AND THEY SAID THEY WANT TO
COME A MITCH McCONNELL
COMPLETELY CAVED TO THEIR
THREATS, AND HE DID IT AT THE
LAST MINUTE.
THANKS TO HIM AND OTHER WEAK
REPUBLICANS IN THE U.S. SENATE,
DEMOCRATS, WELL, THEY HAVE
MONTHS TO WORK ON A SOLUTION AND
GET THEY ARE $3.5 TRILLION BILL
BACK UP AT NEW GREEN DEAL
SOCIALIST SPENDING BILL THROUGH
CONGRESS.
MITCH McCONNELL PLAYED THE
TYPICAL SEWER SWAMP GAME OF
SAYING ONE THING, DOING ANOTHER,
NICKING A PROMISE, AND BREAKING
IT.
BY THE WAY, DEMOCRATS ARE NOW
MOCKING HIM AND TAKING A HUGE
VICTORY LAP.
MITCH McCONNELL CAVED AND
THAT'S THE HEADLINE THAT
SENATOR ELIZABETH WARREN,
SENATOR ELIZABETH WARREN IS
CORRECT.
MITCH CAVED, THIS BRINGS US TO
AN IMPORTANT QUESTION FOR
MITCH McCONNELL.
WHAT WOULD YOU WILL COME AT A
REPUBLICAN LEADER THE SENATE,
REPUBLICANS I THOUGHT AND AM A
REGISTERED CONSERVATIVE BECAUSE
I HAVE SEEN TOO MUCH OF THE
SWAMP WEAKNESS IN MY LIFE, I
LEFT THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
WHEN YOU'RE RIGHT, I WILL DEFEND
YOU, AND IT'S NOT LIKE I HAVE A
CHANCE OF SUPPORTING DEMOCRATS,
THERE RADICAL SOCIALISTS.
WHY WOULD YOU SUPPORT RAISING
THE DEBT CEILING KNOWING WHAT
THE DEMOCRATS PLANS ARE?
THAT'S TO SPEND A $3.5 TRILLION
ON THE SOCIALIST GREEN NEW DEAL?
MITCH McCONNELL'S OFFICE
CLAIMING THAT HE WAS LOOKING TO
AVERT IN DEFAULT WITH A
SHORT-TERM EXTENSION AT $1 WITH
A FIXED DOLLAR AMOUNT.
AT LEAST THEY RESPONDED TO US.
WHAT MITCH IS NOT SAYING IS THAT
HE AND THE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS
SAID THEY WERE UNITED AND WOULD
NOT DO THIS.
THEY PROMISED NOT TO DO THIS.
MITCH NOW GAVE DEMOCRATS HITS
PRECIOUS TIME, NOW THEY CAN WORK
OUT THE DISAGREEMENTS ON THEIR
MASSIVE SPENDING DEAL.
BY THE WAY, ONE THAT WILL BE
RAISING AT A RECORD LEVEL,
AND THAT WILL CAUSE INFLATION
TO SKYROCKETS AND HURTS EVERY
AMERICAN FAMILY.
ALREADY, INFLATIONS CAUSING THE
AVERAGE AMERICAN HOUSEHOLD.
DO THE MATH, THAT'S $2100, AND
INFLATION TAX ON EVERY SINGLE
AMERICAN HOUSEHOLD.
HE'S ONLY BEEN IN OFFICE NINE
MONTHS.
GAS PRICES AND THE SEVEN YEAR
HIGH, FOOD PRICES ARE UP THROUGH
THE ROOF.
THE PRICE OF RAW MATERIALS ARE
UP.
EVERY EXAMPLE, EVERYTHING YOU
BUY AND PAY FOR IS UP.
EVERYTHING IS UP.
THINK WHAT $5 TRILLION IN NEW
SPENDING WILL DO.
EVERYTHING YOU BUY WILL BE MORE
EXPENSIVE.
YOUR PAYCHECK WILL BE LESS
VALUABLE.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, JOE BIDEN'S
BUILD THE BACK SOCIALIST PLAN IS
A DOWN PAYMENT FOR THE
$10 TRILLION THEY REALLY WANT
WITH THEIR NEW GREENDALE
SOCIALISM.
GOVERNMENT PAID FAMILY LEAVE
THEM A GUARANTEED JOB,
GUARANTEED GOVERNMENT PAID,
GUARANTEED GOVERNMENT PAID CHILD
CARE, GOVERNMENT PAID COLLEGE,
TUITION, AMNESTY IF YOU WILL
WHEN YOU GET -- OH, YOU DON'T
HAVE TO PAY YOUR LOANS BACK.
OKAY.
I WISH I HAD THAT WHEN I WAS
PAYING MY LOANS BACK.
ANYWAY, BILLIONS FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS, MASSIVE GOVERNMENT
ENTITLEMENTS FOR EVERYONE WHO IS
UNWILLING TO WORK.
I WROTE THE BOOK.
OF SOCIALISM, ITS HISTORY OF
FAILURE.
WHATEVER NAMES IT'S GIVEN,
WHATEVER MANIFESTATION TAKES ON.
WE WILL TAKE CARE OF YOU.
OKAY, THE SAME PEOPLE WHO SAY
THEY KEEP THE CITY SAFE AND DO
NOT, THEY CAN'T MAINTAIN LAW AND
ORDER, THE SAME PEOPLE WHO
DESTROYED OUR SCHOOL SYSTEM?
THE SAME PEOPLE THAT BANKRUPTED
SOCIAL SECURITY AND MEDICARE?
THEY BROKE OPEN THE LOCK BOX AND
SQUANDER THE MONEY, THE SAME
PEOPLE WHO PROMISE TO KEEP YOUR
DR. PLAN AND SAVE MONEY.
THE UNITED STATES IS THE
GREATEST SYSTEM EVER CREATED.
IT WILL BE UPENDED.
OUR GREAT ECONOMIC SYSTEM AND AS
WE KNOW IT.
THAT'S WHAT'S AT STAKE.
MITCH McCONNELL, IF YOU'RE NOT
WILLING TO FIGHT, FOR BASIC,
SMALL GOVERNMENT SIMPLE
CONSERVATIVE PRINCIPLES, SMALLER
GOVERNMENT, LESS REGULATION,
CAPITALISM, FREE-TRADE, FAIR
TRADE, ET CETERA, IF YOU'RE NOT
WILLING TO FIGHT TOOTH AND NAIL
KEEP YOUR PROMISES AND PROTECT
THE COUNTRY, THEN WHAT WE KNOW
DOESN'T WORK SOCIALISM.
IT ALWAYS ENDS IN UNFULFILLED
PROMISES, ALWAYS ENDS IN MORE
POVERTY, AND IT ALWAYS ENDS WITH
PEOPLE GIVING UP FREEDOM AND
IT'S JUST A MATTER OF HOW MUCH
FREEDOM YOU GIVE UP IN THE NAME
OF FULL SECURITY.
BUT, MITCH, IF YOU'RE GOING TO
BREAK YOUR PROMISES, THEN YOU
NEED TO STEP ASIDE